to ask you to direct a review
of the irs 501c policies
because it's my belief that for a long
time the policies of the irs have been
very misaligned with the statutory
direction that congress gave
the irs over these agencies and that to
a degree
the irs was um bullied
into taking these um non-statutory
positions
because there was so much blow back from
the dark money forces and from their
mouthpieces
when they tried to intervene um i think
the 501c
problem and the extent to which
anonymous money is now interfering in
our politics is deadly serious
and i hope uh when i ask you uh you'll
take an honest look at this
and not appoint someone to do it he'll
give it a whitewash
and instead take a really good hard look
at what went wrong
a senator i would be very glad to work
with you on that you're
pointing to very disturbing
um situation and
um i'll need to get up to speed on uh
where things are with that but i would
be uh glad to
initiate a serious review of this matter
good um another serious matter is um
freddie mac warning of a coastal
property values crash around
the country because of climate change
driven sea level rise
uh 40 sovereign banks warning of
systemic global risk to the economic
system from
climate change uh economists warning of
a carbon bubble
that will clobber the u.s economy
and given how serious all of that is i'm
wondering
where your senior level climate person
will be
in the department of treasury there's no
specific office
how are you going to staff addressing
climate at the most senior levels of
treasury
well i will look to appoint someone at a
very senior level to lead our efforts
and to create a hub within
treasury in which we particularly focus
on financial system related risks and
tax policy incentives toward climate
change
i think we need to seriously look at
assessing the risks to the financial
system
from climate change
the federal reserve has recently
said that they would be joining the
network of supervisors for greening
of the financial system uh there
are development methodologies to do that
and we'll focus on that in a word or two
how seriously do
do you think we should take freddie
mac's warnings of coastal property value
crash
the sovereign bank warnings of systemic
risk and
so many economic economists warnings of
a carbon bubble crash i think we should
take these risks very very seriously
i think climate change is an existential
threat
and um both the impact of climate change
itself
and policies to address it could have
major impacts creating stranded assets
um generating large changes in asset
prices
credit risks and so forth that could
affect the financial system
so these are very real risks and
systemic risk is a mild phrase but it
conveys a very powerful
message doesn't it yes it does
last question does um i believe that
foreign corruption and kleptocracy
is inimical to our national security
interests
um for too long the u.s has been a haven
for international corruption and
kleptocracy
through our shell corporations
um with intense leadership from mike
crapo who i want to give a big shout out
to here
and sherrod brown we got into the
national defense bill
the beneficial ownership reform uh
incorporation transparency bill another
tedious name for something that's
actually very
uh brutal and essential and i'm
interested in
who you think will lead the effort of
cleaning up that mess
using this new statute within
treasury and how high up within treasury
will you place responsibility
for cleaning up the uh
dark money shell corporation problem
that america has
has fomented so let me start by saying
that this is a very important
problem and that the act that was
recently passed by congress gives us
an enormously potent tool to address
this problem we will try to get up and
running
as quickly as possible and devote
ourselves
to building that database so that we can
address
these issues and we'll be
certainly looking to give this very high
priority
you agree it has a national security
dimension absolutely
that's it for me thank you very much dr
yellen i really look forward to working
with you and to uh bob casey my
apologies for
jumping ahead of you thank you senator
whitehouse
senator portman
thank you mr chairman and uh to dr
yellen thank you very much for your
time you gave me recently to talk about
uh many of the issues that i know have
come before the committee today
uh i'm gonna revisit one that i'm sure
has been talked about uh which is
the fiscal discipline question a
treasury secretary can be very powerful
within an administration
uh providing a voice for fiscal sanity
and uh i i would urge you to do that
our conversation was about the
relatively low interest rate environment
the fact that you think that investments
are needed and that going into
further deficits and adding to our debt
is appropriate
um i would hope again that
although we do have relatively low rates
today
knowing that that could change we
shouldn't get too comfortable with that
and second that we have historic levels
of deficits now
um and as a percent of our gdp not seen
since world war ii which is frightening
um one quick story when i was omb
director under the bush administration
this is
a long time ago 14 years ago
i wanted to propose a balanced budget
over five years and and
and uh there was the ability to do that
only 14 years ago think about that a
balanced budget not over 10 years but
over five years
in the budget there was quite a debate
in the administration at the time
and uh frankly i think i was on the
losing end of it until somebody weighed
in
and that was hank paulson who was then
secretary of the treasury
and i always be grateful for him for
that i think it was the right thing to
do at least it showed that we could get
to a balanced budget by making some
tough decisions
um and the treasury secretary obviously
was someone who
uh people were listening to from an
economic point of view so with that
i i don't know that i've posed a
question
but i would love to hear your response
to what you see as your responsibility
to be a voice of fiscal sanity within
the administration
i completely agree with you senator
portman that
um the treasury secretary has to be
a voice for fiscal sanity and i pledge
i pledge to do that um our finances need
to be
on a sustainable long run course
and um that's very important for us
uh to fo to focus on i pledge
i pledge to do that um right now
short term i feel that we can afford
what
it it takes to get the economy back on
its feet to get us through the pandemic
and um to relieve the burdens that it's
placing on
households and small businesses and
research from other countries suggests
that often spending money to address
a weak economy um ends up
creating a lower debt burden in the long
run
than failing to provide that support so
that will be my focus
uh in the short run is getting the
economy back on its feet
but longer run there are challenges in
achieving fiscal sustainability
we have to make sure ultimately the
deficits
that we run if we do that are consistent
with
fiscal sustainability the world has
changed
i believe the future is likely to
bring low interest rates um for a long
time
but of course it is a risk that interest
rates can rise
and we need to consider that risk as
well in
crafting a sustainable and responsible
policy
thank you the i i will uh look forward
to working with you on coming up with
ways to deal with that long-term
structural deficit
because we all know about it we all know
it's there it's a mandatory spending
site of the ledger
and uh i've talked to you about this in
our conversation
privately but i do look forward to
working with you on that
the tax cuts and jobs act was passed in
2017
and the resulting economic improvements
were dramatic
we had as of february as i recall 16
straight months of wage gains of three
percent or more
before covet hit unbelievable we had
poverty rates at record levels since
poverty rate began to be
measured back in the 1950s we'd never
had a rate as low as we had
going into the pandemic and obviously
unemployment was low
historically low for many groups
including blacks hispanics
and and others so this is uh
you know this is a good thing we had an
opportunity economy
that uh many of us uh talk about but it
actually was happening and i think a lot
of it was because of the investment that
businesses were making small and large
alike
because of the tax reform that really
made it more
advantageous to invest in america 482
billion dollars in equipment buildings
and most importantly to me employees by
u.s businesses during this
time period after the 2017 bill
and before the pandemic hit let me ask
you if i could about
one part of that and that is the
corporate rate
my understanding is that president-elect
biden has talked about raising the
corporate rate
and also raising the uh amount of
uh taxes that that one would pay uh for
global income
um both of which i think are going to
result in less
investment in the united states and the
whole reason we lowered the rate was to
be sure we were more or less competitive
with the rest of the
developed world our rate is still
frankly when you include the state
income tax higher than the average but
it's about at the average whereas before
we had the highest rate
among all the developed countries and
you know what people were doing is
investing overseas not in america and we
were losing jobs we were losing
businesses
companies were inverting losing
investment and much of that has started
to come back
it's been a good a good thing the
the bill introduced uh a concept of not
just lower rates but also this global
intangible
low tax income the guilty regime which
is very complicated but basically it's
anti-base erosion meaning that it
effectively acts like a
minimum tax on foreign earnings of u.s
companies
prior to that companies could just defer
their taxes forever because our rates
were so high
uh people deferred and deferred and
deferred now they have to pay it and
it's uh
you know it is kind of a minimum tax um
the the high u.s tax rate we had before
made the deferral necessary but it also
caused this lockout of foreign earnings
as
a barrier to u.s investment again
created incentives for
acquisitions of u.s companies by foreign
companies they could get a better deal
so we both lowered the rate and
eliminated deferral
as a result we've created a more level
playing field
i just am worried about these proposals
to both increase the corporate tax and
to double
double the rate as i understand it on
guilty on this minimum tax from 10 and a
half to 21 percent
um it would it would put us again in a
non-competitive situation
relative to our oecd trading partners
and uh you know the oecd right now is
considering a global minimum tax rate of
12.5
so they're going the opposite way
because they get it this creates more
jobs in
in in their countries so i hope that you
will push back against that
understanding that um you know
you may not approve all of the tax cuts
and tax reforms that were in there but
certainly on the business side this
created an incentive to invest in
in america senator
the ability to to write off your
investment senator portman we're
on a time schedule here because another
committee needs to take this room so
could i ask that to be a question for
the record
well i would love to hear your response
for for the to on in
the record for that again i appreciate
our conversation on that and other
issues and
um i i look forward to hearing from you
thank you thank you and dr yellen i know
you've responded to that type of
question a couple of times but if you
could give a very thorough response in
the question for the record because i
thought that was a
very well stated question thank you
chairman
uh thank you next we will return to
senator casey
mr chairman you can hear me now yes we
got you okay
thanks dr yellen thank you for your
willingness to serve the american people
again we're grateful for that
i wanted to focus my questions maybe two
broad questions mostly on
children but they'll touch on other
issues as well
first of all the the role of both
child care and early childhood education
so-called early care and learning
the importance of that to the economy
and in particular
to the labor force participation by
women which we know
is a major challenge we have the
pandemic
has exposed the importance of
caregiving on our economy those who care
for and support
children who support and care for
seniors and people with disabilities
we're seeing more clearly now probably
than ever the
the importance of quality affordable
care
for those americans and the connection
between that care and our
economy in in president-elect biden's
american recovery i'm sorry american
rescue plan
he included a provision very close to my
bill the child independent care
tax credit the expansion of that and so
i just wanted to ask you about
both the question of child care and the
care
economy as an economic imperative to the
country
if you could discuss both your ability
to
elevate this issue both as it relates to
covet 19 as well as the importance
in terms of the short and long-term uh
competitiveness of our economy
well thank you for that question senator
um i feel this is a really critical
area both because of the pandemic and
longer term um it
the availability of child care and paid
leave
um greatly affects the ability
of women to participate in the labor
force
and once upon a time we had one of the
highest
labor force participation rates for
women
of any developed country and that has
really
changed and we no longer are anywhere
near the top
and where we stand out is
that the united states does much less
on the front of child care and paid
leave
and most other developed economies and
i agree for the competitiveness of our
economy
and wanting women to be able to
participate
it's really critical to address those
shortages
and it's been more than evident in the
pandemic
it's women who have suffered a
disproportionate
loss in jobs who have a disproportionate
burden
of caring for children who are out of
school
and for relatives
who are ill and need need help
and it's really impacted them
mightily in it because of a
lack of these supports
well i appreciate that because uh it's
it's um
i think very very much apparent now
because of the
pandemic about how important those those
programs are and those strategies are
for for caregiving
my last question before my time runs out
uh dr yellen is about
kid savings accounts this has been an
idea that's been around
uh proposed over the last 20 years
i've worked with senator wyden on the
young american savers act
it's a measure that i proposed a similar
measure
in the debate on the 2017 tax bill the
democrats all voted for it
um it's i think it's time finally to
enact
savings accounts to support equity
building
for our nation's kids so we can also at
the same time support
emergency savings for their parents
could you discuss
briefly and i know we only have less
than a minute left
the the role of asset building in
securing the middle
class well just very briefly senator i
certainly
um agree that assets um are utterly
essential
for people in dealing with an emergency
it's shocking
that such a large fraction of americans
wouldn't have four hundred dollars
to deal with an emergency and it's
necessary for
homeownership for business formation for
saving
and we have huge wealth disparities
even greater than income disparities
and the racial wealth gap is also
worsened over time
so looking for strategies to address
that gap and promote asset building i
think
are should be very much the forefront of
policy
well dr yellen thanks so much good luck
in your confirmation of some other
questions for the record thank you mr
chairman thank you
senator thank you senator gracie senator
hassan
well thank you mr chair and ranking
member wyden for holding this important
hearing and doing it today
thank you dr yellen for appearing before
the committee
and for your willingness to serve our
country during this difficult time
having someone with your expertise at
the treasury is going to be pivotal
to helping struggling families and
businesses as we work to contain the
virus
protect and create jobs and rebuild the
economy
i have three questions that i think we
can cover in our time
as we discussed when we met earlier this
month dr yellen
i am working on a bipartisan effort with
senator young to expand the research and
development tax credit
for small businesses new businesses and
innovative startups are a major source
of job creation
which is going to be key to rebuilding
our economy after we contain the virus
dr yellen could you speak to the
importance
of r d investments to creating jobs and
to the economic recovery
and at the treasury will you work with
us to explore ways to support r d
through the tax code
thank you senator um certainly i look
forward to working with you this is a
very
um important matter r d
is essential to innovation
and to the growth of our economy it's
made a huge contribution
and i think you're absolutely right that
new businesses and innovative businesses
have driven job creation
so finding ways to support
r d investments and including by smaller
new businesses
is something i'd look forward to working
with you on
well thank you dr yellen as we continue
to assist struggling businesses
to keep their employees on payroll we
also need to strengthen support for the
risk takers and
innovators who create new jobs and help
us grow the economy
toward that end the recent economic
relief package contained a bipartisan
bill that i introduced to senator burr
to allow small businesses to both
participate in the paycheck protection
program
and to claim the employee retention tax
credit
unfortunately according to the national
federation of independent businesses
one of the supporters of our bill many
small businesses remain
unaware that they can receive upfront
payments
of the employee retention credit to help
keep workers on payroll
and cover employee health care costs dr
yellen how can treasury increase
awareness of the employee retention
credit so that small businesses can
quickly and effectively
receive the full range of economic
relief available
well senator i first let me say that i
think
allowing these businesses to utilize
both
ppp and the employee retention credit
was a very worthwhile innovation
and should really help a lot of
businesses so
we want to make sure that they know
about it i will discuss
this i promise with the irs to see
if there's something that they can do
but perhaps we can also work with
non-profits and
with groups like the federation for
small businesses
to see if we can find ways to publicize
it
um so that they're aware that this
is a benefit that's available well thank
you i think this is a
an important factor in helping us
accelerate the recovery and
protecting jobs so thank you for your
willingness to
work with us on that um i wanted to
switch topics a little bit to the issue
of terrorist financing
in previous finance hearings without go
secretary mnuchin
i've raised the importance of treasury
programs that combat the financing of
terrorist and criminal organizations
the bipartisan national defense
authorization act
passed earlier this month and it
included a provision
led by senator warner that established
an advisory group with treasury
to counter new ways that terrorists use
emerging financial technology
one area of growing concern for example
is the potential for terrorists
and criminals to use cryptocurrency to
finance their activities
so dr yellen can you outline some of
these emerging technological concerns
and how treasury
should combat new forms of terrorists
and criminal financing
senator i think you're absolutely right
that the technologies
to um accomplish this change over time
and
we need to make sure that our methods
for dealing
um with these matters um with tech
terrorist financing
change along with changing technology
um cryptocurrencies are a particular
concern i think many are used
at least in a transactions sense mainly
for illicit financing
and i think we really need to examine
ways
in which we can curtail their use and
make sure that
anti-money laundering doesn't occur
through those
channels thank you thank you mr chair my
time is up i look forward to working
with you dr yellen
look forward to working with you as well
thank you and next is senator cortez
master
senator craig thank you mr chairman
senator senator crypto with
leave from my colleague for nevada and
in no way um taking from her time
i'd just like to take maybe 90 seconds
to
describe where i think we are with
respect to the yellen nomination i hope
that'll be
acceptable to my colleague from the
nevada be very quick and
this does not come off her time yes so
the majority and minority have been
talking and we now have an agreement
that finance members
senate finance members will have their
questions in for the nominee
tomorrow yeah close a business tomorrow
close a business tomorrow
so my hope would be uh senator crapo
that we could have chair yellen
on the floor of the united states senate
on thursday
and obviously we're taking it a day at a
time and we
made some headway here in the last hour
deadline for
uh senate uh questions i mean
this is a person who's been confirmed
again
and again and again and has all these
past treasury secretaries
in in back of her so um i appreciate the
discussions that we've had
in the last um you know hour we've made
some progress i hope she'll be on the
floor
um on on thursday thank you well thank
you senator wyden and
i will talk with senator grassley and we
will work with
members on our side to work
expeditiously
thank you now senator cortez
thank you thank you mr chairman uh dr
uh yellen uh congratulations thank you
for the courtesy meeting last week
uh i'm gonna try to keep it brief it's
been a long morning and afternoon for
you
and i've thank you so much for your
patience and
i enjoyed listening to all of your
responses to my colleagues
two issues hospitality and we talked
about that
and the other is housing so let me just
talk a little bit about
as you well know in nevada we've been so
hard-hit before the pandemic the travel
and tourism industry
was one of the largest sectors of uh of
the economy in 2019
travel generated 1.1 trillion in
spending and supported 15.8
million american jobs but the covet 19
pandemic
has devastated the travel industry more
than any other sector of the economy
and according to oxford economics the
u.s
lost 510 billion in travel spending and
4.5
million travel jobs in 2020.
so my question to you is what are your
recommendations for addressing
this hardest hit service sector uh
economy and its workers
like those in nevada and across the
country
well senator cortez masto i'm
really aware of just how badly
the nevada economy has been impacted by
the pandemic
because of the focus on travel tourism
leisure activities this is the whole as
you said the hardest hit
sector with the most pain and job loss
and getting this pandemic
addressed and over with so people can go
back
about their lives and travel and enjoy
leisure activities that is top of agenda
and in the meantime making sure that we
support
the workers and the businesses that have
been so badly affected
giving them the aid they need to get
through this
come out the other side and to help
state and local governments in a variety
of ways
reopen schools make sure that you don't
have to
fire emergency workers because of the
budget pressures that um your state
faces
and others thank you dr yellen but let
me
be a little bit specific last fall
senator kramer and i introduced a
bipartisan bill it's the hospitality and
commerce job recovery act
and what it does is it provides
refundable tax credits for businesses
and individuals to boost
demand for travel once it's safe to
travel again
i'm curious what what are your thoughts
are can tax credits be effective tools
to incentivize spending and help certain
sectors like the service sector and
travel
sector recover and the economy turn
around
well sarah i'd be glad to take a look at
that and work with you
and examine the details more fully
i appreciate that thank you as you said
in your introduction
you know that the sector particularly
the service sector has been so
disproportionately impacted
we need to continue to provide relief
and investments
in this sector so i'm hopeful that you
and the obama administration will work
with us
moving forward housing i know i don't i
have a minute left let me ask you this
uh and this was an issue nevada is
literally literally dealing with an
affordable housing crisis
um that started even before this
pandemic i know it's happening across
the country
um and we talked a little bit about this
could you men
really address how treasury department
can work with us to
as well as the biden harris
administration to address
what we see in affordable housing crisis
across the country
it's a huge problem senator and we
really need to
devise effective ways to work on this
and support affordable housing um
things like the low-income housing tax
credit i think have been
very important and we need to come up
with other innovative strategies
because this this really is a crisis in
many parts of the country
well i know my my colleague senator
cantwell mentioned this to you as well
uh during this hearing i look forward to
working with you as well as the the
biden administration to address this
issue
thank you again uh for your willingness
to serve
thank you senator appreciate it
thank you senator cortez nasto senator
young
dr yellen it's good to see you again i
enjoyed our visit the other day
congratulations once again
i would like to ask you uh for starters
about
some questions about our hardest hit
businesses
um you know it has been widely reported
that we
are in the midst of a k-shaped recovery
where
uh wall street doing pretty well so many
of our small businesses doing well
uh in fact record profits we've seen
from a number of them
meanwhile a number of our main street
firms are are
if not hollowed out certainly uh just
talk marked with uh businesses that are
shuttered under canada's pandemic and in
associated
public health measures in your july 17
testimony before
a house subcommittee
you indicated doctor that there would be
scars
left on the economy and by that i infer
you probably meant uh an erosion
of skills within our workforce a loss of
innovation that tends to occur
among these small firms to say nothing
of the future opportunities
for growth in the state of indiana it's
estimated that one in four small
businesses
face closure including you know
generations
deep family businesses that have really
become
pillars within given communities so
there's a social and cultural dimension
to this as well
that's all if economic conditions do not
improve
blessedly we've invented these vaccines
and
and the economy uh will be opening up
and
we have a relief package that we came
together and passed
to the american people before years in
in in light of that relief that we have
offered it seems to be making a
difference
there seem to be some sunnier days ahead
what do you expect the need to be
for additional small business assistance
and and why do you expect
that need to exist to a particular level
well unfortunately i fear we have some
very difficult months ahead before the
vaccine has been
widely enough disseminated to
really open up the economy and let
people
get back um to their regular lives
going out to eat at restaurants and
engage in entertainment and
things that involve face-to-face contact
so i think the ppp funding
included in the last bill is
tremendously
important we are going to do everything
we can
to work with the small business
administration
to get that support out as quickly and
as effectively
as we can these small businesses are the
lifeblood of their communities
and provide a disproportionate share
of jobs in america and so supporting
them
i think of scarring is not only
affecting workers but
when businesses fail that have been the
backbones
of their communities that's permanent
job loss
for workers and a tragedy for the
communities
so this is certainly something we
want to do and if more funding is needed
we would come back and ask for that
we've asked them
for some money for grants for the
smallest businesses and
um some funding to support uh state and
medical
nonprofit in getting a assistance out
well and and i have to say that seems
prudent to me doctor
um i it's my sense informed by
uh conversations with people on the
ground as well as economists that
there will be additional assistance
needed for some of our hardest hit
businesses but we're going to have to
continue to monitor that i think that's
the right approach
i also sense it's prudent again after
consultation with others
to hold off of certain campaign promises
uh that might have been made and i want
to get your perspective on that
in particular tax increases in the
middle of a global pandemic
uh which has triggered this massive
economic downturn
so the focus now is not on tax increases
it's on um programs to help us
through the pandemic but we also
the president-elect also wants to pursue
his building back
better agenda um to
strengthen the economy make sure that we
create good jobs at good wages for
workers
and invest in infrastructure in our
people and in that context
there may be a need for additional
financing
we shouldn't think about tax increases
in the abstract
i think any anything that is proposed
should be um focused on uh
corporations and on um high income
individuals and in the context of a
larger program yes doctor so i
i won't focus on the abstract let me get
uh very particular are there any
elements of the revenue
raising portions of the buildback better
plan that you believe should be
reconsidered
i'm not sure what you have in mind um
there have been a few things that have
been specified
um but probably not a complete program
um president-elect biden has
proposed increasing the corporate
tax and making um american companies
that offshore
jobs um reducing those incentives
and in doing that i think
worrying about the competitiveness of
american business
uh would propose to do this in the
context of
on global agreements on corporate
minimum
taxes i'm grateful for the answer i'll
have to uh
probably submit some follow-up questions
for the record pertaining to the loss of
jobs
right now should companies uh invert
that is send their headquarters overseas
with seeking lower corporate tax rates
which was one of the
uh reasons that uh the rate was lowered
initially but nonetheless
we need to avoid that for sure yes well
good we
we agree on that as a matter of
principle um you and i discussed
my proposal with senator bennett uh
to create a long-term working capital
loan program
for our hardest hit businesses it's
called the restart act
60 bipartisan co-sponsors were earned
here in the united states senate
roughly 180 in the house of
representatives and thousands of small
businesses in
indiana and across the country were
supportive of this uh to the extent we
need additional
small business relief and you've
indicated we might is this something uh
that you might work with me and senator
bennett
uh to uh try and perfect and perhaps
implement in a bipartisan way
absolutely i would look forward to
working with you on that
thank you so much thank you senator
young
senator's ass thank you mr chairman
dr yellen congratulations on your
nomination
obviously an important capstone to a
very distinguished career
um i want to focus on a set of topics
that involve the national security
equities of the treasury department more
than some of the topics of the last
couple
of questions it is my view that whenever
the senate is fulfilling our advice and
consent obligations
with regard to any senior position that
has national security equities
one of our obligations is to make sure
that the nominee in question regards
herself or himself
as having a national security portfolio
uh and secondarily
i think it's it's clear that there is a
bipartisan
consensus in the senate now i come to
you having just been an
intelligence committee hearing first
open and then closed
and the bipartisan consensus is
overwhelming uh that the number one
long-term geopolitical
threat the united states faces not just
in the next four years but probably in
the next four decades
is the chinese communist party so i want
to ask you two questions about that
first
dr yellen do you believe that the
secretary of the treasury is a national
security position
uh in the in the president's cabinet
absolutely i think treasury along with
um the rest of the administration needs
to stay laser focused on that
we have many tools that are implemented
through treasury to address
national security concerns the treasury
heads the leads the cypheas process
and have sanctions and enforcement
actions
that can serve to dismantle financial
and support networks
of those um who seek to do us harm
and certainly leadership
uh of treasury is is important and
it's a priority thank you i'm glad to
hear you said that dr yellen both the
the cypheus point
and the the portfolio and the sanctions
regime i also
um in the past uh have chaired the
subcommittee
of banking that deals with with
sanctions and i agree with you that you
have a very important
and and uh professional staff in that
area and i'm glad to hear that you
regard it as a priority
do you regard the chinese communist
party as an existential threat to the
united states
well china i regard china as our most
important strategic competitor and
um feel it's necessary to
devise a an administration-wide and
multifaceted approach
to address the threats
that china causes and
um certainly we need to
target illicit activities that are
linked to
uh theft of intellectual property and
trade
secrets um illegal efforts to
acquire critical technologies and
sensitive u.s
data um and fentanyl traffic among other
things
thank you i agree with your list in
addition i wonder if you would regard
chairman xi and his regime as guilty of
genocide
in xinjiang at present i think
it's guilty of horrendous human rights
abuses yes
thank you i i do think the word not to
quibble here won't make you
respond precisely to the word genocide
but i think it is important for us to
recognize what has been happening in
xinjiang as a genocide
and so it is not just one one issue
among
many uh where we can sort of varnish it
as
merely a geopolitical competitor um
chairman she's regime is evil
and they are raping and torturing uh
uyghur women at present so
i think we need to be well aware of the
nature of the regime we're dealing with
obviously the most one of the most
important pieces for the purposes of
thinking about the future of the us
economy is the long-term technology race
we face with china
for years american economic and
technological innovation have
fueled the ccp's mastery of the digital
economy and then they've gone on to use
that mastery of the digital economy to
do
a parade of horribles some of which you
just listed
uh importantly could you walk us through
how you think about
a review of our technological
interdependence uh
with china and do you believe that some
degree
of decoupling is going to be incumbent
upon us in the next four years
well i do think that we face
a significant competition um with china
and need to address the subsidies that
china has put in place in other policies
to
erode our technological edge i think
first and foremost we have to make sure
that we as an economy make the
investments that enable us
to compete with china investments in
manufacturing and infrastructure and
training and research and development
that are
ultimately our sources of economic
strength
but we need to aggressively
um counter um unfair
practices that china uses whether it's
to enforce technology transfer
or to invest in ways in the united
states
that um that
are dangerous to our national security
thank you i agree with you that there
are a number of strategic areas where we
are under investing
from ai to quantum to
to biotech to robotics machine learning
etc but as relates to
5g in particular and huawei could you
use that as a case study to talk us
through
kind of how you think our policy should
be unfolding in the 5g space
and how we should be trying to bring
together allies to battle
the unfair practices uh that we see from
huawei around the world
and senator ask me i ask that you make
that a qfr
because we're running against a tight
deadline here yes
chairman uh dr yellen i'll i will make
that a qfr
and uh again congratulations on your
nomination and we look forward to
working with you on these topics
thank you senator says thank you senator
sass
we are running up against a tight
deadline here because we have to have
the committee
of this room available for another
committee but we're going to return to
two
senators senator toomey and senator
menendez and then we will wrap up the
hearing
and with that senator toomey uh thank
you very much mr chairman
um dr yellen i want to talk just a
little bit about
housing reform housing finance reform i
should say uh
which i think is in some ways the great
unfinished uh business of the financial
crisis
as you know the gs fannie mae and
freddie mac are
still in conservatorship uh still
perceived as too big to fail
now they hold almost no capital um
but um secretary mnuchin and um director
calabria
of the fhfa did take some significant
steps that seemed to me steps in the
right direction
while i would have preferred going
further uh
at least there uh is an end to the
automatic profit sweep
there is the opportunity to build up
capital through retained earnings
there is a capital target now for the
gses
and there are rules that are meant to
limit the uh acquisition of the riskiest
loans by the gses
um have you had a chance to look at
these
um reforms and
um have you determined that you would
support
leaving them in place senator to me it's
it's a very important matter nothing is
more important to the future of
housing in the united states then
what we do with fannie and freddie and
i need to look carefully at what's been
put in place
and ultimately we need to find
a solution that has bipartisan support
and to work with congress to craft an
approach um okay uh will you commit to
developing and releasing reform
principles
for both on the regulatory side as well
as
on the legislative side um we will
certainly give
priority to studying this
issue and i'm coming up with ideas about
what should be done okay and and just
quickly to follow up on the conversation
we had the other day
about the f sock designations um
you know one of my concerns has always
been that sippy designations create the
expectations of a taxpayer bailout
should a problem occur
in a way it designates the the firms
that are so designated as too big to
fail
um interestingly um
certain categories of financial
institutions have not been designated
and it occurs to me that certain
business models are inherently
less of a risk to our financial system
for instance asset managers that simply
hold assets on behalf of investors as
opposed to banks
that intermediate credit and transform
maturity
um so asset managers have not been
designated as siffies
thus far do you agree with the decision
that's been made
not to designate at the managers at
sippy's thus far
well when i served on f soccer's fed
chair
um it was proposed to look at
activities that asset managers engage in
that might pose systemic risks and
a paper was issued that um
mentioned problems of possibly
looking at high leverage and hedge funds
a working group was
formed that
was to look at i think it's since been
disbanded
the matter of whether or not
some hedge funds have dangerous levels
of leverage
um open-end mutual funds that promise
daily redemption and liquidity that
invest
in um assets that
are relatively illiquid can pose
problems uh and i think we saw some of
those problems
in march uh
foreign
one two
and i would point out that the money
market funds have been remarkably stable
and
successful but i appreciate that and
look forward to working with you on
these and other issues thank you mr
chairman thank you senator toomey and uh
is senator menendez back i'm being told
that he has not been able to make it
back and so that will conclude the
questioning
dr yellen you've made it through to the
end of the hearing
i know this was a long day for you and
and
we appreciate the fact that you are
willing to serve that
we congratulate you on your nomination
and as has as you've probably heard in
some of the discussion
a number of the senators will want to
submit to you
questions for the record some have
already been stated here
during the questioning period others
will be
submitted in writing those questions for
the record are due
by close of business tomorrow and as
senator wyden indicated the committee
does want to move expeditiously so
we ask you dr yellen to please respond
to these questions for the record as
quickly as possible we do what we would
like
some thorough answers to some of these
to all of these questions but
please respond to these as quickly as
possible
and with that again dr yellen thank you
so much for being here with us today
and this hearing is concluded
b
you